hey good morning joy how are you hi
carlos how are you doing
i'm doing very good i'm really excited i
mean like we're a week away
from i know 2054.
all the prep all the dancing and it's
it's like
just seven days away what's the most
that you're excited about like what's
what makes me most excited about this
project
well i'm i'm really just excited about
like the togetherness
i think you know when calling it studio
2054
it was really a play on words with my
fascination with
studio 54 and that era and although i've
only lived
through it in the sense of pictures and
documentaries and videos and stories
i found it so amazing how so many people
from
grace jones to sheik to elton john to
liza mannelly all these people are all
just like mingling with each other and
it almost feels so
surreal to imagine and so in this sense
studio 2054 is a very modern take
on bringing so many people so many
versatile performers from
all different backgrounds from you know
uh
singers dancers artists actors
acrobats roller skaters you know
everything it's a whole world around it
and i just
love the idea of being able to bring all
that together to create a show
that everyone can watch from home and
because i haven't been able to tour
and because my well my tour had been
postponed or has been postponed now
twice
it was kind of the main reason i wanted
to put
this do this live stream and to
to be able to finally perform these
songs from my album future nostalgia
that i haven't yet been able to to
perform and i've been
dying to get on that stage to do it and
so we've been working really really hard
to create something
very unique and very special um
for for everyone at home but also for us
and for the band and
for the dancers because we we were just
about to we were just about gearing up
for rehearsals for tour and then
lockdown happened
yes it feels really good for us all to
be back together especially in london
at home um and to create something very
very special
i love that you and your team have taken
advantage of the situation
and are creating something new how is
this unlike anything you've done before
well um for one i don't think anybody
has seen me
um doing something like this for sure
um i think i've definitely i'm
definitely pushing the boundaries
of what people expect of me
um which i'm really excited about
because i feel like i've learned so much
about myself i feel like i've
found this new found confidence in my
performance and who i am as a performer
alongside an
artist and songwriter um which was
really important for me
especially with this record and so i'm
happy that i felt like i
really pushed the boundaries on this one
for this show
and alongside that you know i would
never really be able to
put on a show quite like this on tour
you know we're very lucky that we get
the opportunity to shoot it in a
warehouse
and have these custom built sets from a
from
an 80s tv studio to a roller rink
to like a boiler rave new york party
and all the way through there's like all
these little moments and interactions of
guest
performers and guest appearances that
are just so
fun and so exciting and to get to
collaborate with these artists in in
this way as well is is a whole new
dimension and a whole new experience of
learning and working with each other
which i'm i'm really really
excited about yeah it sounds incredible
i i know fk twigs is gonna be there
who else are you super excited about uh
sharing the space with
oh i'm so i'm so excited angel who i've
got a song with
uh called fever she'll be joining me in
london
fk twigs is joining me i'll be making an
announcement for another guest that's
joining me today at 6 00 pm uk time
uh which i'm really excited about there
are so many guest performers
and guest appearances which i'm i'm
gonna some i'm gonna announce before the
show and some i'm just gonna leave as a
surprise for the show
um but it's it's it's very exciting to
to get to share the stage with these
artists and
to come together and collaborate and
especially for
the fans and listeners i love the
unexpected and
uh that's been something that's been
very very exciting for me
you said that you've been rehearsing
every day for like six or seven hours
dancing your ass off quote unquote
every single day are you like at your
most confident now with the kind of work
that you've got behind you
i think you know i do keep telling
myself that with the amount of
rehearsals that i've done and the amount
of times that we have
run the show like boot camp i know it in
my sleep
and i can do it in my sleep that's i do
feel very confident in it
um there's obviously you know when the
cameras come on and the adrenaline
starts rushing
and your heart starts racing you have no
idea what happens at that point but i am
very
ready and excited and i i i mean i've
never done anything like this
so there's definitely gonna be nerves
and adrenaline but it's gonna be
this is this is everything i could have
ever dreamed of
in terms of of being able to put on my
own
tv show if you will yeah what's the best
like
what's the best exercise for being able
to keep up your cardio for that length
of time
while also belting out like your
students
simultaneously well i i guess what i've
done for that is
being able to just build stamina um by
just constantly
running the show but we start every
dance rehearsal
with like a full worm warm-up abs
cardio you know mountain climbers
everything that you can
and then we just run the show for about
five hours non-stop we're just going
we're fixing we're
changing bits making sure that
everything is very slick and tight and
uh we know exactly what we're doing and
then we would round up and end our
rehearsals with some yoga and i think
all those things are kind of you get a
little bit of you get centered and
grounded and
you're ready to go and at the same time
i'm i'm singing
so the more i practice the singing the
more i know exactly how i need to move
in order for my voice to work
the way i want it to so i don't
and so it's just it's been a massive
learning process you know it's it's not
easy to
to do the dance we're doing and to be
able to sing live
and i'm i'm really really working hard
on it so
i'm uh i'm excited to to see what
everyone thinks
i've i don't think i've worked harder
for anything in my life really
we're also really excited about prisoner
which just dropped and the video is
wild thank you was it
was it just kind of a a free-for-all
there do you plan everything that's
going to happen like the cherry juice is
an iconic moment that's miley's
maraschino cherries so that was
it was all it was all um obviously with
it with a video treatment it was all
planned out
but it was very much a kind of runaways
pastiche
kind of joan jett sherry curie us going
on tour
it being like a very fun you know 80s
glam rock kind of moment between the two
of us which
i feel like when we got into the studio
together it was like the perfect
amalgamation of where we are
in terms of our um sound stylistically i
felt like it it really kind of
we met each other right in the middle
and i think it just worked perfectly
um and i'm really really proud of the
song and it was so fun to work with
miley and to collaborate with her she's
she's a blast and um i'm so excited the
video is finally out and everybody gets
to see it and
hear the song i mean if anyone's going
to lick you in the face it's got to be
miley cyrus
you said it now
you're it's exciting for you that you
get to reveal everything that's going on
about your um your concert online but
you actually revealed the whole thing
and had elton john tell you to your face
that like you're his favorite
and your album is the best album of the
year like
when does that ever stop being
incredible when you are working with
all these idols and icons oh no every
day is a pinch me moment
for sure every day i'm going what is my
life and what am i doing and this is
surreal and
i mean even when i found out that elton
john had agreed to to talk to me about
studio 54 because i wanted to pick his
brains about what it was like to be
there and
you know to to soak up even more
information
for for the live stream and he was just
so
wonderful and amazing and i i'd spent
about 24 hours prior
just like writing down questions and
changing them
rearranging them and making sure it was
trying to do
you know trying to be a good interviewer
and it was
you know it never stops being exciting
and novelty and
and you know every day is really truly
as a pinch me moment i i feel so lucky
to get to do my job and sometimes i do
stuff and then i look back on it and go
like
that was so mad and surreal and i'm so
grateful for all these moments in my
life i'm i'm truly i'm truly grateful
well i mean he's not wrong i know so
many families and individuals that say
that this album is incredible my kids
my kids love it as well so i mean we are
super
super looking forward to to this big
event on the 27th
thank you so much send all my love of
course thanks for your time
you